et s'il est bien un produit dont le prix
a chuté c'est l'ordinateur familial des
prix / 6 en 10 ans et non pas par trois
comme je vous le disais l'ordinateur n'a
plus rien d'un produit de luxe
une grande marque vient même de lancer
un modèle à 500 euros
elisabeth sd didier rancoeur poids 1 kg
4 prix 499 euros à san francisco steve
jobs directeur général d'apple présente
son tout petit dernier une mini unités
centrales vendues sans clavier ni écran
ni souris en fait un produit d'appel
pour reconquérir des parts de marché
toujours plus petits et toujours moins
cher selon les vendeurs de ce magasin
l'ordinateur ne cesse de baisser
30 % de moins que l'année dernière les
clients font le même constat gp 1899
euros
je pense que oui effectivement les
années précédentes il aurait coûté
beaucoup plus cher et si on remonte plus
loin en arrière on voit qu'en dix ans
les prix ont baissé de 85 % très
globalement car les performances
évoluant constamment il est difficile de
faire des comparaisons
malgré tout les consommateurs ne
débourse pas forcément moins car ils ont
du mal à résister à toutes les
nouveautés les clients dépensent plus
intelligemment
davantage en fait ils veulent plus de
technologies aux prix les plus bas
mais présente plus non plus deux on
compte un match en plus de ventes
du coup le taux d'équipement des
familles a plus que doublé en six ans
passant de 20 à 40 2 % et tout le monde
s'y met parce que l'ordinateur ne sert
plus seulement à travailler et à faire
du traitement de texte c'est devenu
avant tout un instrument de loisirs
multimédia sens